أغبى إعلان شكرا جزيلا لك
سافيدان يبحث عن الأضواء شكرا لك
الوفد أيضا أن يتهمنا
أهلا وسهلا أعتقد مثل wafd و wall-e
بدأت التبادلات المكثفة و
كان ذلك في ذلك الوقت في فرساي ونحن
لم تتوقف عن التحدث إلينا
كنت في الواقع قد التزمت ب
الخريف الماضي للرد على بلده
دعوة ولذلك أنا سعيد جدا
أن تكون اليوم في سانت بطرسبرغ
200 م ليراها داني بدار فرنسا
أيضا حقيقة فرساي 7 ولايات من
مجلس الشيوخ الأخضر وفاء في فيراري وفيد
يوم الثلاثاء
هنا أصداء d'arbois tata هذه
مراكز رسم لتذكر
تطوير العلاقات الاقتصادية
أعتقد أنه شيء جيد بالنسبة لنا
ستحصل على عقود مهمة و
الطبيعة المتنوعة للغاية التي سيتم التوقيع عليها
خلال هذه الرحلة حوالي خمسين
وحوار المجتمعات المدنية
قررنا معا قبل
الآن اتخذت شكل عام لها
الهياكل وسيعقد أول اجتماع لها
الجلسة العامة هذا الحوار تريانون ونحن
يمكننا رؤيتهم غدا
الفنان ادريان
لقد علمنا أن دراجة نارية قد ذكرت بالفعل أن
الرجال هذا الجسم المنجل الجديد
بالطريقة التي تهدد بها مثل هذه الحالة جبنها
خفيف إلى معتدل ابنه في تايزيه بالماء
أحد سبا أشتون والبلوغ و
ثنائية أعتقد أن اللحظة
نحن نعيش يفرض أن بلدينا
الأعضاء الدائمين في مجلس إدارة
أمن الأمم المتحدة مع أ
تاريخ قوي سياسة
الدولي الذي كان دائمًا قويًا
ويمكن بناء مستقلة
سواء كانت أوكرانيا
الشرق الأوسط للأزمة الإيرانية
والوضع في سوريا
سواء كان هو أيضا الطريقة التي
نرى التعددية
المعاصر أعتقد أننا بحاجة
العمل لأخذ زمام المبادرة
البلديات
وبالنسبة لي فهي أيضًا واحدة من
أهداف هذه التبادلات التي في نظري
هي أيضًا مهمة جدًا لهذا الغرض
صوت وطني
ن غدا قال بن لادن مرة أخرى يوم الثلاثاء
صوتها أجش رانيا شوكولاتة أو ساتا
لكن لا شيء يفعله الخردل المبتسم
سباحه أو بدرة